this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much Jeff for that
generous intro and i hope i can at least
somewhat appease everyone since they're
here okay so one of the greatest
challenges that we have in the 21st
century as you all know and implants is
trying to connect genotype to phenotype
but also i think one other grand
challenge we have is trying to feed more
people highly nutritious food and where
my research lies is in crop nutritional
quality high throughput phenotyping and
analyzing quantitative complex trade
variation in crops so the large thrust
of my presentation will focus on this
these two parts right right here and
there'll be parts of in terms of like GS
and G wasps as well so when we think of
the the world's population now we were
at seven billion people but for the ones
that are in less developed country we're
at 5.8 billion and when you think about
the people who are not getting enough
calories and in the foods that they're
eating or there and they aren't eating
foods it's over 1 billion people but
where I draw my passion and where I kind
of drive my research right now and what
is you know is the thing that really
gets me up out of bed every day early in
the morning is trying to work on this
question of two billion malnourished
people in the world and when we think
about this we can think of things that
are extreme so there are these
populations in the world be it n South
America Asia or sub-saharan Africa that
are highly deficient in things such as
vitamin A iron zinc and iodine and then
things that are just like chronic but
very much targeted in certain
subpopulations would be such as vitamin
E
and b vitamins so of the traits that i
focus on in my lab are generally
pro-vitamin a iron zinc vitamin e and b
vitamins and so for the past almost
eight years now my colleagues and my
group have been trying to figure out
ways to improve variation for these
traits and in maze but be before we go
there I would like for you to think
about what could be a possible panacea
for solving this grand challenge that
may have and trying to improve the
world's nutritional value of the food
crops that they eat we can think of
giving pre-made vitamins out we can
think of having the food process and
we're artificially adding vitamins to
the food we can also think of increasing
the amount of fruits and vegetables that
people are eating or perhaps fish and
eggs so all of these are part of the
puzzle and and the one I would like to
focus on now biofortification and that's
where we're trying to use variation in
plant populations being genes to try to
improve the quantity of these different
nutritional compounds so it is certainly
possible one could trade take a
transgenic approach to this and now you
can think about even in the future after
we find the causative variants such as a
crisper approach could also be used but
in the case of maize which I will now
focus on we've been able to use the
populations that already are present say
in the tropical and temperate parts of
the world and harnessing that variation
in plant breeding populations without
having to take a transgenic approach but
when we think about mais oui we all love
maze it drives our econ
here in the US but there are some
countries such as Zambia here in in
orange where over fifty percent of their
calories are coming from maize and why
this is a possible issue is we think
about maze it's a great source of
carbohydrates those calories that i was
talking up earlier but what it lacks is
a lot of the nutritional components that
these at-risk populations very much
needs such as vitamin a vitamin e b
vitamins iron and zinc the great thing
about maize it has tremendous natural
variation for these important phenotypes
for this world's population so we can
think about harnessing it in a
biofortification approach so what that
first requires is trying to find the
genes and in a sense at the end because
of the variants that are controlling
that this variation in these plant
populations so one of the traits that
we've heavily focused on in my group is
pro vitamin a and after it's consumed
say by humans it is then converted into
what we now know is vitamin A but let's
at first look at the impact of vitamin A
in the world when you think of these
at-risk populations that are not getting
enough vitamin A into foods that they
eat there are seven million pregnant
women 127 million priests preschool age
children are vitamin A deficient and if
you look at this green area right here
and such as like Zambia where as I was
saying earlier half of their calories
are coming from maize and they're at
least like twenty percent of the
population is severe for being deficient
in vitamin A vitamin A deficiency causes
600,000 I
a childhood 2 f's each year and
blindness and 500,000 children each year
so the thing that drives us when you are
a plant breeder you have the opportunity
to create something that can be of value
to humanity and this is in a sense where
my passion lies because all of this is
preventable and this is something we can
tackle as plant breeders but with trying
to ask any question when it comes to to
plant breeding you have to ask a
question what is the composition for a
particular compound in the grain in this
case we're looking at carotenoids and if
you look here the highest proportion are
zeaxanthin and lutein those are
obviously very important for the health
of the eye but they have no pro vitamin
A activity at all so of the compounds
here there are basically three which
have Pro vitamin A activity but my
favorite and the one that has highest
pro vitamin A activity our friend beta
carotene right here but as you see here
is only six percent of the total of the
carotenoids found in grain of maize now
let's think about it in terms of the
continuous variation in a population for
this compound so on average in a
population of temperate and tropical
lines that is capturing a lot of the
variation in the public breeding pool on
average 1.7 so to put that into context
harvest plus has a target of tenfold
that so on average we need to increase
beta-carotene by tenfold as you see here
though at the tail it's only 7.5 okay so
what you should then be asking yourself
as plant breeders is is their superior
alleles that we can recompile
in these likes a tropical maze during
plasm populations that we can increase
pro-vitamin a two or even greater than
this this target that's been set by
harvest plus so that's that's a
challenge that we have here now the
other tray we've been working on in my
lab is vitamin E so there's something
that needs to be clearly defined here
there aren't really extreme deficient
populations in the world for a vitamin e
there are populations in various
countries that are not getting enough
vitamin e in the foods that they eat so
even in the u.s. here there are 26 or
forty percent of people that had plasma
to tocopheryl at a concentration that
was actually lead to an increase of
cardiovascular disease that's 26 to
forty-one percent in the US and when we
think about it now in terms across the
world there hasn't been a lot of work on
vitamin E as there has been on vitamin A
so we don't really have a good handle on
what are the at-risk populations across
the world but for what has been re
reported we see that there are some
countries such as Brazil and who knows
what this country is Tunisia very good
melody very very good
obviously the French are very well
trained on your geography so here we can
ask the same question and in this case
alpha tocopherol has divided the highest
vitae media activity in grain of maize
but as we see here only eleven percent
of all of the cocoa criminals ie vitamin
E compounds are come come comprising
what you would actually find in grayned
of maize but then when we look at the
continuous variation as we did with the
pro vitamin a here we have an average of
eight point one nine so if if we can do
some calculations based on eating 400
grams per day on what someone would
require on average you're talking about
breeding like 42 maybe fly fold higher
on on average in a population so this is
something that it actually seems to be
more tractable right but there's a catch
that I will show in in a few of upcoming
slides so so now we have the challenge
here we want to find what these
causative genes are and we also want to
find whether the superior alleles
patrolling this variation in these
populations and everyone's favorite
hammer the maze damn population here it
has been genotype with hapmap version 1
and version 2 and we've had two
outgrowth of this population and if we
can include all the checks and controls
we are pushing close to 20,000 hplc runs
on on this seed which as you would
imagine required chaining for postdocs
to for hplc s for two years of course
they weren't chained but that's just
kind of give you an idea here but the
so the the positive here if there is one
we can actually phenotype carotenoids
and took a criminal's at the same time
from the same grain sample and one other
thing of value is here so we have the
hapmap version 1 and 2 the hplc data and
we've done RNA seek on 6 time points on
grain after it has been pollinated so
you can think about over these six time
points of the 25 founder lines of the
population here and so what that then
gives us the chance to really do here is
ask the question what in a sense what
genes are turned on and off over the
phase of kernels but also it allows us
to ask the question for the cutie LS
that we find which ones are actually II
QTL and when these eqtl are actually
turned on and so obviously i can show
hundreds of these plots but i will just
be showing two so here what we innocents
are finding is for our favorite pro
vitamin a and compound beta-carotene for
you know this one has the highest for
vitamin A activity there are only seven
QTL that are controlling that phenotype
so as as you should be thinking as
breeders this is something then that is
very tractable because when you think
something as complex and yield there
could be hundreds to perhaps thousands
of genes controlling that variation but
for this in terms of like the
composition trait in the grain itself we
are only finding 7q tl's in this
population but I would also like to
offer that there are most likely rare
variants out there that haven't been
captured in this population that could
become
contributing to variation as as well
when you think about it as as a crop so
of these QTL we found five hits that are
in very well defined candidate genes
from the carotenoid pathway so that
gives us a pretty good feeling and in
these five QT l's which had what we will
refer to as a priority ins had very
large effects as well whereas these two
that are unresolved had effect sizes in
terms of across the population that were
actually very small so in a sense we're
able to define and determine what these
causative genes actually are for the key
QTL controlling this this trait in this
population and this is where the RNA
seek data can become very valuable
because then we can begin putting all
the QT ELLs on a time access and so what
we are seeing here these are the effect
estimates for the QTL themselves and
this is the log-transformed FP km value
for for the gene okay so you can kind of
just kind of view it like copies poor
for the gene and each of these founder
lines here but what we're seeing here
for this one gene does crit RB 1 which
is as I see here is converting
beta-carotene to beta crypto xanthine
which has only half of the pro vitamin A
activity as this compound here and this
is very much an eqtl and it's constant
over the whole if if you will phase of
the colonel ok so in here it's turned on
at 12 days after pollination here 20
days after pollination so sort of thing
here that's very valuable is so we're
testing the effect sizes or the effects
themselves of the queue
GL with the gene activity ok so in a
sense we're able to then say that this
is in fact in eqtl and since five of the
seven QTL work on controlling variation
and from a pathway we now have the
opportunity to really design a pathway
breeding approach to improving pro
vitamin A in maize and here in this case
we have these two genes right here which
you can kind of view them as you want
them turned on very highly because they
are generating the precursors ok and
this is a psy one gene right here this
is the first enzyme going into the
retinoid pathway and you want this gene
to be turned on very high as well
because you want to take all the flux
from here and have it going down into
the carotenoid pathway and then if we
have in allele of this epsilon gene
right here that is weak then the
activity of this gene will be low and
then the flux will then shift over to
this branch point over here and why that
is important because this is a side with
beta-carotene which has a pro highest
pro vitamin A activity right and so we
have to have a break in our pathway to
so this is where the crit rb1 comes into
play if we have a weak allele of this
gene here that means less beta-carotene
will be converted to this compound which
has only half of the pro vitamin A
activity so now when we think about
breeding for provide high pro vitamin A
content becomes very much a
combinatorial breeding approach when
you're just trying to recombine the most
optimal variation at each of the genes
to get the highest quantity of pro
vitamin A in maize grain and in
i would say in the past five to six
years these two genes here have been
used to release hi pro-vitamin a hybrids
to the country of Zambia and and and now
having worked with very much closely
with harvest plus with my colleagues now
there are over 10,000 farmers in Zambia
that are growing this orange hi pro
vitamin maze so I think one thing that's
you know obviously very valuable when
you're being in a plant breeding
Department is is obviously you want to
do cutting-edge science but we have to
reduce what we are doing to practice to
have an impact on the people that we are
trying to help and I think one of the
key points here is that if we just
created something something that's kind
of like a foreign concept of high pro
vitamin A orange maize and brought it to
a country like Zambia they probably
wouldn't eat it because say it for the
past hundred years they have been eating
grain that is white from maize and as
innocence has no Pro vitamin A at all
okay so there's like a strong cultural
preference to eat the grain that is
white but because of outreach and
education from groups like harvest plus
they actually go into the towns and they
educate the end user that eating this
maze will save the eyesight of your
children and perhaps also their lives
because if you don't bring the public in
from the very beginning we cannot expect
that they will use something that we
have created over the past 10 years so
now Christine in my lab has been
carrying out some some work where we
have been trying to ask a question okay
we've been breathing for high vitamin A
what happens when these this pathway
which we have now characterized very
well is being perturbed by heat and
drought and that's some of the things
that she's been carrying out now and as
as I'm pretty sure the seeds have been
planted the plants are germinating and
and there they are growing and we have
everything in place that we will be
receiving ship grain coming in this
coming year and then we will run hplc on
it but that you know the thing we have
to ask ourselves with like climate
change as well we where we've been
testing all these high pro vitamin A
lines under well irrigated happy places
right now let's put him out in places
where they have to go under go heat and
drought which is very much going to be a
reality that that the plants and then
the people will face going forward so
now to vitamin E and what I showed
earlier was a very tractable trait in
the sense we were able to find what the
causative gene was for those five QTL
now for alpha tocopherol which has the
highest vitamin E activity this is a
case where 13 QTL are controlled this
phenotype and when we look to see what
the candidate genes are we only can
figure out two of them one thing I would
also like to point out is this BTE for
gene it's able to capture half of the
phenotypic variation that we see in this
population whereas these this one
candidate gene here and all the ones
that we can't characterize their percent
variation accounting for the phenotype
it's actually two person or less so we
have now really tried hardly to to like
tease apart these QTL
thing about plants they like to keep
things like this very tightly to the
best ok so these these are the things
that are very challenging to tease apart
so of these we we have I would say five
very good candidates that we have been
able to tease apart and it seems like
transport is actually fairly key in in
to sell and for this pathway so this is
in contrast to the crib rb1 approach
whereas here 12 days after pollination
we don't really see any trend at all in
a sense the activity that in the gene
being turned on isn't a tracking with
the effects of the QTL at all only 20
days after pollination do you really see
that enzyme begin to convert gamma
tocopheryl to the compound that has the
highest vitamin e activity so this has
obviously earlier we can then begin to
have an idea of when these QTL are
turned on so then we can then have high
hypothesis that can be tested where then
perhaps we can find a cutie l that is
turned on 12 days after pollination and
then we can ask the question is that
going to lead to higher content in the
grain itself so those are things that we
are asking now and after now carrying
this board our our grant was just funded
so here we've been previously working on
pro vitamin A vitamin E now we're
beginning you tackle B vitamins and zinc
and iron and this is by d woo in our lab
as you see here where the beginning to
analyze b1 b2 b3 and b6 and in the grain
of maize and in the 281 panel we're
finding quite a bit of variation so we
think when they go to a panel say over
two thousand lines will you be able to
find greater variation and these blue
ones right here these are the the lines
that we are employing and crosses now
because we're trying to ask the question
why is this an it's like an extreme
phenotypic outlier is it a QTL that's
you know how does it actually work so
that's that's what we're trying to
figure out now and this is AG wasthat
was run just this past a few weeks in in
the maze aims panel and d woo i'm happy
to say you have some hits here that that
look very very promising that will be
able to follow up for for up the trade
of iron and why this trade is very
important iron deficiency impacts over
two billion people worldwide so this is
like one of the most important traits
that we could be breeding for in maize
and all of this information now that we
are generating in pro vitamin A
carotenoids vitamin E took a criminal's
B vitamins zinc and iron are actually
now being able to feed into my own
breeding program because the third most
important vegetable in the u.s. is in
tomato is in potato it's sweet corn I
know I was surprised as well and would
you believe people eat over 20 pounds of
it per year I don't consider myself one
of those people but hey there's some
people that could be eating quite a bit
of corn ok so so the thing that we have
been doing for the past two years is
growing a very large panel out in the
field and since these traits we have to
phenotype on fresh kernels right ah so
this is a little more challenging or
what we have been
in a sense in like fuel corn maze we
have to harvest a fresh and then the
ears themselves are in a sense kind of
frozen out in in the field and then
their ground up frozen and then we run
hplc on it thank you Matt for doing all
this hard work and all of this is
actually beginning to turn into some
some real jiwa hits so our friend right
here on chromosome 5 which is that key
enzyme the converts gamma tocopherol to
the compound that has the highest
vitamin E activity we hit that same key
gene in this panel but the question we
have now though is the most favorable
variance already in this panel or do we
have to begin crossing between germ
plasm pools and that's the real
challenge and we hope not but if we have
to then we have to and we are also doing
gs4 for this breeding program and there
were 100 crosses this this past year
thank you again Matt so here here we are
now doing GS and this if you will this
is like pro vitamin a and this is the
combo of these three compounds that have
the highest provide a minute activity
and these two compounds here if you
recall are the ones that very critical
for eye health so this is just for one
hplc run and and so we we think this
will improve over time so here for for
this tray with its at point six and here
for these these two traits which have
high pro by many activity we're close to
point to but part of the challenge with
this is is this panel has been genotyped
with TBS and as we've seen in our prior
work we need to closely tag the
causative jeans if you will in the panel
and there there are some genes we are
not tagging very well
and so sorry Matt we're going to have to
do some targeted pcr to actually pull
those out possibly or we can just do
whole genomes and call it a day I'll
have you choose which one you want to do
so so the one critical question that I
had back in two thousand nine after we
were generating all these hat maps were
what about the phenotype and and that's
when I began working on the field based
hi to put phenotyping and in my prior
job on cotton because even though we
think with GS we're going to have to do
a lot less field phenotyping we have to
do it for the training set and we have
to do it repeatedly over time to update
the training models as well okay so in
in my prior work we created this high
clearance high-throughput phenotyping
tractor here and everything is run on
GPS so we can figure out where the
actual train is is coming from in a plot
and our field map is on a GPS
coordinates as as well and we're able to
look at vegetation variation from canopy
reflectance canopy temperature and
canopy height and in a great thing with
this tractor was we were able to do it
over the whole growing season and I
didn't have to be out there like 2 p.m.
in the afternoon when it was 120 degrees
Fahrenheit we just had someone driving a
tractor 30 just so you know our riri
vamped tractor all this call it now has
a cab with AC on it so all this this
looks very draconian if you will
someone's having to drive distracted
through the field things have been
realized and their improved now so
actually it's all on GPS and everything
so the person in the tractor cab doesn't
even have to touch the wheel he or she
just sits in there and it just drives by
itself and they're in a
CN for all I know they could be having
some like film fest in there or
something you know because you don't
have to see where you're driving at that
point and and so this is where you have
a question that you're asking and the
tool isn't created so I had the question
in in terms of like how much variation
is therefore say can it be temperature
and kind of quantify that over time over
their whole growing season and can i
find QTL that is actually controlling
that variation at each of the key time
points over the growth phase of cotton
and here we had every common in inbred
lion population so this was very
humbling when I went into cotton there
were no very large population so I had
to use what was basically created for me
at first and then we here we had the
high-throughput phenotyping tractor and
then we had a cotton picker driving
through to do traits which was like
yield fiber quality traits and some
plant food straights is Tim setter here
I was going to give a shout out to him
for thank you for doing this plant a say
here but I'll highlight that reading
results soon so here we we have our
actual test year so here we had dry rep
one which is basically our drought this
one here is our couldn't control treated
as wet then dry rep to and wet rep to
right here and and the great thing is
all growing on on drip and it hardly
ever rains in Arizona although I will
say if you do plan a drought test it
increases the probability of rain I have
seen even in a place like Arizona and I
think one other key point is we had to
characterize the variation for the soil
as well such as like clay and sand
content because whenever you're doing
any drought testing the soil will have
more variation than your actual plant
population for the phenotype that you
are testing so just to kind of give you
an idea of where we are here so you
here we were at planting right here and
up until first flower everything was
treated the same and in terms of the
drip and at flowering is where we began
imposing the droughts treatment and and
in traits that we were also doing where
canopy temperature this is a vegetation
II and to see here and canopy height and
this is early in the morning 10 am-1
p.m. and it's in in the afternoon so in
a sense you're trying to capture the the
variation over the whole growing season
here as we're doing is this eat every
week but also capturing the variation at
each time point within each of those
weeks and so the the three growth phases
that we were targeting were at flowering
and as post flower and as we have the
growing fiber as well and then of course
yield and the fiber quality traits that
were collected as well and so this was
just published this this year and one of
the fascinating things with this work is
prior to this there really wasn't a way
to quantify it for a like hannah p
temperature in the field it had to be
all by hand but traits like this can
actually change change with with time
very rapidly so then you can think you
would and maybe have to have an army of
people to do like 400 in some plots just
for a traders canopy temperature but
this case the the tractor could
phenotype all of the plot in a half an
hour and here we have each of the years
so it's 2010 2011 2012 and this is the
treatment wet and this would be the dry
drought treatment here and if it's red
then we have a QTL in a sense as
increasing the canopy temperature if
it's blue we have a QTL that's
decreasing the canopy temperature then
so if Tim was here he would be so
excited that s Isaac ass
it actually hit one of our key canopy
temperature QTL and this is actually
showing up pretty early on in the growth
phase of the plant and its carrying
forward towards harvest as as well under
the two treatments and why that is
important because this is a plant
hormone that is innocence controlling
transpiration rate so since we also have
a QTL that is going right here it's a
possible candidate gene but as you're
trying to find candidate genes you
should always have the caveat you can
always find a candidate gene right but
this one actually you can tie in with
the biology very well and the actual
compound itself maps to the same place
as they can it be temperature qto and
then we also wanted to ask question can
we use this to also track with with
yield and what we found out is the
plants that take or in a sense take a
great risk and I will say this because
these are the ones that plan to use a
lot of water and can continue to cool
their canopy here these are the plants
that will be trying to conserve the
water and then they won't cool their
canopy so for the plants that are grown
here if you recall everything is grown
under drip in a hot arid world okay now
for the one set are going to continue to
trend transpire at a high rate they're
going to continue to fix carbon and if
they're going to continue to fix carbon
there are going to have higher yield but
if you are perhaps growing in a dry land
part of the world you would perhaps want
a genotype that will conserve water
early on and then we'll in the sense you
use more towards the end of the growing
season such as like rain fill or fill in
this case for old fiber
so what we also figured out was that
canopy temperature at flowering was most
predictive of yield at the end of the
season and and the reason why that was
it's it's clear now to us that if
there's high heat what do you think is
going to happen to that pollen apollomon
isn't going to be very valuable right so
that is kind of like what is happening
here so if you have a high heat event at
flowering it'll have a great impact on
the pollen the pollen will be in a
viable and then you won't have any seed
ie cotton fiber okay so we know wanted
to ask the question after Cotton's bendy
foliated in a sense you add a chemical
that drops all of the beautiful green
leaves you can then drive a combine
through it here right so this is in a
sense creating a cloud point map of all
of the cotton plants in our field and in
a sense what this is is you take
something that's like bright laser you
shine it at a plant it comes back time
of flight and then as its returning you
calculate the time and then you can
recreate like a 3d map of the actual
plant itself so since this is the
defoliant cotton what I really wanted to
do with this was actually try to count
yield and how do you do that count the
cotton bolls so here's a case where we
have one plot now and so since this con
has been defoliant you can see this
right here these are the cotton bolls
right here so this piece of e equipment
was kind of put on the tractor and here
the tractor is driving through the field
and we're recreating the geometry of the
plants them themselves and then you can
pull out one plant and then use a
Euclidean clustering approach and then
you're using that to count the cotton
poles on the plant which is in a sense
yield because there are actually
you know cotton breeders I grow out
hundreds of thousands of plots and they
don't want to combine all of those all
at once right they just want to target
just those like f2s or F for plants out
in the field so this could be valuable
for that so now that was was cotton and
now with this myth maze so we kind of
had the question how do we do plant
pathology in a cornfield it's all by I
it's all with human beings if I'm out in
the field I guarantee you I probably
won't be accurate like tier if he's out
in the field so how do we move that
subjectivity from plant phenotyping and
if you're wondering this is the one
that's the corn light okay so can we
find the actual blight out in the field
so this is where artificial intelligence
actually comes into play and then tying
it with drones because we should now
kind of view drones as almost our
colleagues and our co-workers and so
when I yes it sounds a little
frightening so when when you have this
drone flying through a a cornfield can
you have it so that it's taking a photo
and then it's analyzing that photo
telling you if a certain pathogen is on
that corn leaf and then tell the actual
grower where he or she should go to the
field to either of apply a chemical
we're actually you know chopped a plant
down or something like that so what we
have here is an actual drone photo of
corn field and this would be a beautiful
corn vision right there right though the
challenge is I can easily find this one
can we train to AI to go through
thousands and thousands of photos that
have been taking over the course of the
year to then find it
and I think one of the most you know
painful things is training this AI
because you have to have actual a true
in effect plant pathologist that's
telling yes no yes no yes no so training
it I think is I think almost like the
hardest part and you may have to train
on thousands of actual photos and and to
kind of get an idea of how this works
from the easiest way I can tell you is
it's in a sense converting pixels into
words okay yes vs no and so after the AI
has been been trained we can then take a
photo from the field that thanks to tier
that that he took and then we can apply
the AI to that plant and in this case if
it's black that means probability of
zero if it's very bright white
probability of one so in this case it's
finding all of them on the leaves right
here and then it's finding even some
right here on that leaf so probably one
of the real challenges is trained this
AI is when you're out in the field you
also have a lot of soil and other plant
parts and fragments if you will covering
the ground and also weeds okay and then
we can also ask a question in the case
where we don't see any do you find any
and in this case no so how well our are
we doing I think we're doing pretty well
but we can always be a lot better but I
I'm kind of happy with that but
sorry so now let's talk about robots the
20th century was all about chemicals the
21st is all going to be about robotics
and I think when we think about plant
breeding what we should be thinking
about and this is my colleague Josh
where you can then be creating these
autonomous field robots that can do
phenotyping that are going through to
via fields doing such traces like canopy
temperature can it be reflectance and
canopy geometry and what that can begin
I'll actually really ask the question is
what cutie elzar turned on over the
entire growing season and then when you
think about calculating biomass yield if
the robot is driving through the field
every day you can then think about
biomass yield every single day over the
whole growing season and then you can
perhaps begin to really think apart you
know like tease apart gie questions and
where I think this field is actually
heading is so we have the AI and we have
that thing that we call the Breeders I
let's use it to chain to train low-cost
field robots to actually begin to help
select plants from the field so in in
this concept here we have this very
low-cost robot with these thin carbon
fiber legs it can walk through the plots
right so say we had a breeder that may
walk through like 4000 plots and that
breeder is in a sense choosing plants
based on their height and plant
pathology if that breeder can then train
the AI you can then turned out these
low-cost robots just to kind of like
walk through the field and then they can
choose the plants for the breeder and if
the breeder isn't happy with the plants
that were chosen they can retrain the AI
each each
so this is a concept now but this is
where I see the field in the future and
that's where I'm kind of trying to like
drag the field of a plant breeding on
this side aspect of it now with that
there are a lot of colleagues to thank
for this work I won't be able to thank
them all because i'm at a time because
we have the computer problems that first
but with that i'll thank you for your
for your time
yes we yep
yeah so the question that Lee asked did
we find the most superior psy one gene
in a sense i would say at this point in
time no but there are at least two or
three that we have seen but we I don't
know if we found the one that is like
the the the key one and that's that's
where as we're hoping with like the Ames
panel that we may actually find that and
if we weren't happy with it then we'll
just create our own in a future so yeah
yes dear
yes
now it actually has them because like
the part of the seed where those genes
are turned on it hasn't had an impact on
it at all yeah yes
or maybe or overlap
yeah we I I kind of have seen some some
things that have been published but I
don't think they've you know some of its
then been in like greenhouses and growth
chambers and things like that so I think
this has been kind of the P key part
actually taking it out to the to the
field and actually testing it but yeah
there there are some things that where
we we think that we should see and we'll
we'll see if we actually stand yeah yeah
yeah that's phase two but yes yeah yeah
oh oh cool oh good good um so the thing
about took a criminal's it can enhance
the longevity of some of the compounds
in the seed and that's that's what
you're basically saying right
mhm
I think
oh and sorghum yeah okay well good good
okay yeah Susan
the issues one of the many issues the
golden rice debate a high beta carotene
rights which doesn't make it naturally
it's always a transgenic is that they
can get the level but it decreases over
time in storage and rice traditionally
ride down stored over the course of the
season and by the time
they had anticipated so if there were we
can learn from names at a high level of
vitamin foreign Sorbonne that a high
level of vitamin D helps to stabilize it
that could be very very significant for
the way which
calling it was a transformation effort
that early on right afterwards yeah oh
yeah and you know that we we also see
that same problem and in the high you
know corn but the thing is is there is
like an E and a G by E and edgy
component to it and and the g component
I think we can kind of get a handle of
but then there's like a large key
component that I think is more complex
oh okay yeah yeah yeah huh that's an
intriguing yeah sure okay
any questions from geneva this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at cornell edu